ich bin der Meinung leider dass der
Traum von Freiheit ein Traum bleibt der
20 März sollte ja eigentlich der Freedom
Day werden also der das Ende aller
corona-einschränkungen die es in
Deutschland gibt nun merken wir der
Freedom Day wird zum cheating day also
zum betrugstag denn die Bundesländer
fast alle haben schon beschlossen dass
sie die geltenden Maßnahmen verlängern
werden um zwei Wochen bis zum 2 April
das gibt so eine Übergangsfrist im neuen
Infektionsschutzgesetz und sollte das
vorbei sein kommt das nächste hinterher
und da wird glaube ich noch schamloser
beschissen denn da geht es darum
da geht es darum die die Länder also in
großen Einheiten zu Hotspots zu erklären
da kann man dann alles weiterführen was
man bisher schon hat da geht es also
nicht mehr darum dass einzelne Ortsteile
oder Orte ein Hotspot sind sondern ganze
Bundesländer und Karl Lauterbach
ermuntert die Länder geradezu dazu das
ist ein Betrug am Koalitionspartner FDP
denn die FDP wollte den Freedom Day und
der leider hat der Justizminister Marco
Buschmann sich über einen Tisch ziehen
lassen und nun wird die Ausnahmeregelung
für Hotspots möglicherweise zur
generalregelung dann können wir auf den
ST Nimmerleinstag warten bis wir endlich
frei sind das Grün regierte
Baden-Württemberg ist ganz vorne beim
Beschiss an den Menschen es gibt keine
Probleme in baden-württembergischen
Kliniken es gibt 5000 Corona Betten dort
davon sind 1800 in normalstationen
belegt und 250 auf Intensivstation also
alles ganz normal friedlich unaufgeregt
der entscheidende Punkt ist dass die
maskenpflicht zum Fetisch der
Kommunisten geworden ist die wollen sie
die verteidigen sie mit Zähnen und
Klauen denn solange die Menschen auch
beim Einkaufen im Supermarkt gezwungen
sind eine Maske anzulegen
gehen Sie in die Knie vor der dunklen
Macht das ist die dunkle Macht der
Kommunisten sie bleiben unfrei immerhin
die ungeimpften geraten ein Stück weit
zurück ins Leben weil glaube ich die
Impfpflicht im Bundestag scheitern wird
sie wird nicht kommen das haben die
ungeimpften auch verdient sie sind auf
eine Weise aus dem Leben ausgeschlossen
diskriminiert ist für die Impfpflicht
noch mal ganz klar gemacht von Anfang an
gesagt aber ich kann keine Mehrheit
erkennen für eine Impfpflicht ab 18
jedenfalls
das ist
jetzt hast du mich aus dem Konzept
gebracht dann gehen wir direkt
die ungeimpften sind ein kleines Stück
ins Leben zurückgekommen sie können
wieder teilnehmen an Leben nachdem sie
vorher unverschämt und systematisch
diskriminiert und ausgeschlossen worden
sind mein Bild von Deutschland hat das
verändert ich sehe Deutschland heute
anders und ich schäme mich dafür und da
niemand den Mund aufkriegt in dieser
Hinsicht will ich heute Abend die
symbolische den symbolischen Schritt
wagen ich bitte die ungeimpften um
verzeihung aber du hast dich doch immer
eingesetzt dafür ja gegen die Spaltung
hättest du noch mehr tun soll ich nicht
daran das zu sagen das stimmt absolut
ich gebe dir auch Recht ich schäme mich
in der Hinsicht auch Deutsch zu sein für
diese Spaltung aber einer der ist glaube
ich nicht tot ist Christoph Ploss oder
du hast ja nicht dieselbe Ansicht wie
Uli und ich nein also ich finde erstmal
dass auch das was jetzt vorgelegt wurde
von der Ampelkoalition teilweise Murks
ist und auch hier sieht man wieder die
eine Hand weiß nicht was die andere
macht auf der einen Seite zieht Herr
Buschmann sagt Freedom Day und
Freiheiten und die Einschränkungen
sollen und auf der anderen Seite haben
wir
Lauterbach der ja schon in den
vergangenen Wochen ein alarmminister war
so und deswegen man erkennt überhaupt
keine Strategie und keine Linie und das
führt jetzt vor allem dazu dass wir
wieder zum Flickenteppich kommen werden
denn die Bundesländer die können ja
teilweise einzelne Maßnahmen einführen
und dann haben wir die Situation dass
zum Beispiel zwischen Kiel und Hamburg
und zwischen Brandenburg und Berlin
völlig unterschiedliche Richtlinien
gelten und das war immer das was wir ja
von Anfang an verhindern wollten und
deswegen ist das was da jetzt gemacht
wurde echter Murks ich würde aber
trotzdem noch unterscheiden und auch
etwas differenzieren ich bin sehr dafür
dass wir jetzt endlich wieder die
Freiheitsrechte und Grundrechte
weitestgehend zurückerlang ist die
maskenpflicht es gibt es gibt in vielen
er meint es gibt in vielen Bereichen
keine Legitimation mehr das jetzt zum
Beispiel in Berlin ich glaube nur 25.000
Menschen ins Stadion gehen können bei
DSC verstehe ich nicht wobei ich jetzt
heute gelesen habe die Nachfrage sowieso
geringer weil die Mannschaft so schlecht
aber die maskenpflicht halte ich zum
Beispiel im öffentlichen Nahverkehr oder
auch in Supermärkten für sinnvoll weil
da die Virologen sagen dass es eine sehr
effektive Maßnahme und da sind die
Einschränkungen sehr gering also wenn
ich alle anderen Gründe und
Freiheitsrechte zurückbekommen aber weiß
ich stoppe das Virus sehr stark mit
Masken zum Beispiel beim Einkaufen dann
bin ich nach wie vor für eine Masken wir
sehen doch in anderen Ländern die ihren
Freedom Day links hinter sich haben
können wir doch sehen dass die
Abschaffung der maskenpflicht nichts
verschlimmert hat gar nichts in England
laufen in London laufen die Menschen
schon längst ohne Masken rum da gibt es
jetzt keine seit Wochen da gibt es
keinen keinen Ausbruch von der ganzen
muss sie den ein oder anderen Freedom
Day auch schon zurücknehmen
teilweise weil die teilweise auch viel
zu früh geöffnet hatten oder
was kann man nicht sagen
jetzt wirklich die längste these heute
gehabt die ist doppelt letzten Wochen
gab und ich liebe dich dafür aber jetzt
schalten wir einmal ich meine wir haben
ja heute jemanden in einem anderen Land
wir haben ja dieses Privileg wir
schalten zu reifen Möller nach Amerika
und wollen doch einfach mal ein bisschen
wie läuft's denn dort ab gibt es noch
die maskenpflicht wie fühlt es sich
einen Amerika gerade zu leben ist es das
Land der Freiheit
wieder geworden ja also wir können
selbst entscheiden ob eine Maske trägt
oder nicht
ich stimme da Ulli ganz klar zu und
muss sagen dass ja wir haben das jetzt
zwei Jahre wer sich impfen lassen wollte
hat sich geimpft jeder ist jetzt für
sich selbst verantwortlich irgendwann
muss auch damit mal Schluss sein
ich habe was ich in den letzten zwei
drei Wochen noch mitbekommen habe und
deshalb habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch
schon gehört dass es Leute gibt viele
die wurden zweimal geimpft also zwei
plus und so weiter und haben trotzdem
Corona bekommen auch Geschmacksverlust
auch
konnten nicht riechen und so weiter also
es ist halt da draußen ich kann nur eins
sagen geht in die Fitnessstudios
trainiert paar Muskeln Muskeln machen
stark und
gebenukine frei bzw stürzt also eigenes
System es wird wie die Grippe sein
Corona wird nicht mehr wegzudenken sein
wenn wir jetzt die Grippe zum Beispiel
aufzählen würden dann hätten wir auch
hunderttausende pro Tag die sich
irgendwo anstecken es ist nun mal so
weit wir haben ganz wichtig glaube ich
jetzt was ich so jetzt mitbekommen dass
also jetzt in den Krankenhäusern keine
Überbelastung mehr ist das was wir
damals alles hatten das ist ja nicht
mehr klar aber dass sich Menschen
anstecken werden wieder die geimpft
wurden oder nicht geimpft wurden das
wird immer weiter